[Applause]  thank you it's great to be back here at  the Game Awards it's my honor tonight to  present the award for best sports or  racing game let's check out the nominees  best sports racing game  [Applause]  [Music]  I knew with the drama tap you were [ __ ]  taco we got I'm trying to fish fight for  you dumb for that if you don't get a  bullet in your lawn for that stupid I go  give it to me in a move in the blue  flame to no one immortal we're never  that lawyer to my brother never come  ebert out cuz I cheat and I'm flash  better and I love winning I'm upset if  this is time if you  [Music]  get you out the ground just a Nike to  the flow yeah let's go blow for blow  yeah let's go toe to toe when it's time  to batter down never ever show time when  it's time to batter I'm the first one in  the door though here we go  [Music]  you  [Music]